the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody to ultimate moves a
fun and little trash talking event here
at the st louis chestnut to have a bit
of fun after a very serious zinc field
cup the format is very simple we're
going to play 10 games of chess at a 10
plus 5 rhythm in
four games of chess thank you
not that simple apparently uh 10 minutes
plus five second increment and we have
two teams
heading team rex's himself team rex
zinfield
here i got the teams here you'll be
playing white on the first game yes sir
i have a slogan for our team what is the
slogan we're gonna slay the scumbags
all right as far as i'm gonna say that
that's fine all right team rex do you
like your team do you know your team
yeah they're incredible yeah they're
okay team rex will be levon aronia and
fabiano
dominguez and peter svidler and the
other captain today we have john baxter
from edward jones a great partner for
the saint louis chess club we received
tons of sponsorship from them and john
will be part of our board of directors
very soon john excited to be here and
he's not a scumbag
good to know not everyone would say that
but that's good to know we have a slogan
too let's just win just win just win
yes you're gonna do you have to do
better than this in the ultimate moves
but okay john blackstead's team not too
bad gary kasparov janae pomnyacci
alareza farouja wesley so and hikaru
nakamura
do you regret your choices
no what do you mean why do i regret my
choices i got these five wonderful guys
and he's got a bunch of tip shits
yeah but they they got food they got a
larazza
oh they're gonna need him
[Laughter]
all right are we ready to get started
guys
all right let's
start singing
guys
team rex is white to begin the match
let's take a look
the order for the players it is
team rex starts with rex follows with
levon then fabi shock lanier and peter
all right team john everybody here team
john john first gary ii jan third
alireza wesley and then hikaru
i apologize in advance for what i left
him
[Laughter]
but they lose my forfeit
does he start the clock
yes
it says chess club do you think that
they should start a little later
if they don't show up john has to play
those okay
i need to wait
way earlier
[Applause]
we have seven minutes to wait because we
don't have all the players here very
well
we already took our jackets off just
going to be waiting
are you excited for this event yeah i
think we should start now because it's
two players of uh the opposing team that
aren't here you have all our players are
here do you have any shame
no
okay that's easy
all right it seems like we're looking
furiously to see if they're coming
coming by
don't give him any ideas i'm just
worried about
what's your strategy here
i'm gonna i'm gonna follow
yeah very good john
you're on the spotlight right now in
front of a bunch of grandmasters how did
you prepare i'm gonna move two pieces at
a time
preparation did not go very strong guys
[Music]
everybody's just looking at the door
waiting for people to come
by psyching out the other team
have you ever been late to a game
yeah uh
and the last few years thank god
but yeah we're in big trouble i'm
getting defaulted
yeah i mean the default time is
precisely one o'clock did you know that
yeah chris why we can do about it zero
tolerance zero tolerance
now the game and the clock
the arbitrary solution here is to just
forfeit one of the teams
incredible
so the game will be they're all coming
people
they have five minutes to get here
level do you agree that we should have
several tolerance here at this
particular match
zero tolerance is always a bad idea
because we come for an event and we want
to see the event and then you tell the
public okay
the game is off
go
it's bad for the
viewers let me rephrase that you would
win if they don't show up you're the
correct team
it's not about winning it's about having
it
about having a competition and then
winning and demoralizing your opponent
he's just late he's not demoralized
well we got the great gary coming in
but not the last person to join us
is that the late gary kasparov
[Laughter]
is
some last rule checks yeah that's the
hard part yes everybody knows how it
works
wesley we're so excited to get started
what did you do with the money from
2016.
[Laughter]
you guys are having way too much fun
we're trying to get the chess game
started
okay players if you can do me a favor if
you're on team rex can you go to rex's
side please and if you're on team jon
come to john's side
that way we'll figure out that normal's
over here
i'll put a i put a strategizing
microphone here yeah so you're not
playing this here what's going on oh my
biggest worry
for the event was that fisticuffs were
going to break out okay and chest boxing
being what it is these days i didn't
want to
how do you say
tilt the odds
too greatly so i decided to take a break
and just to play neutral you know safe
and secure that kind of thing
do you think that you could be most
people here chas boxing oh god yes
[Laughter]
so long as christian isn't in
the room we're good
where is christian curler speaking all
that so many people missing in this
event
he gets lucky
he's taking the day off much like ali
ali wins two tournaments he thinks he's
great and he doesn't show up
would anybody talk about
what's up with that
uh-oh
[Laughter]
so we've got a replacement
[Applause]
house rules by the arbiter chris
[Music]
sorry
so alareza just showed up so hey guys we
have everybody
on that side ala
why am i saying you guys yeah so you're
not even on a team so
okay really quickly
five moves
next player will come in make five moves
and so on and so on it's very simple
david will here hopefully make sure the
right person sits down at the board
really important you can
trash talk all you want but you must not
comment directly on the position or a
move that can be made in the position
okay let's keep it
there goes my strategy
unless i see something in my venmo
account that is not happening okay
uh everyone has been security checked
and everything is above board as far as
i'm aware yeah perfect
so it looks like we're ready to begin
press that little button
perfect
okay rex keep it on the up and up
please
which match are you excited about right
here this is it this is the big chiefs
i mean i've admired
them all my wife
i'm just kidding
[Music]
bobby how's the opening theory here
uh it's very very theoretical
i played an entire match against maximum
in this lineup
how'd it go
not too well
i mean the opening didn't go too well
and the match
match went well
do you think they're familiar with these
games
no
thankfully
um luckily i don't have to make any of
the critical decisions
these guys however i mean they they have
to play some good games this is another
mistake so it's very easy for me
tell me when they stop making the good
moves
tell me if they stop making good moves
this is all i mean the next like
probably ten moves are all going to be a
theory this is this feels like a top
level game it's way way too uh way too
professional for me i mean what is this
we came to ultimate moves to see like
the boring spanish i know well that's
that's what chess is at all levels
apparently
it's not
responsibility on my shoulders okay
i feel this ten plus five it was way too
much time for the players
okay only two moves
i said it's suspicious
a sequence of three moves yeah
how many moves each
this is four not enough four not enough
no it's free i think it now okay it's
four five this is your fourth here
okay
or on the demons
you've won everything in saint louis do
you need this one too
everybody of course this is the most
important one
of course do you know how this works
yeah of course
all right you ready to get in yes go go
go go go go go get ready
this game is way too responsible
yeah
[Laughter]
are you criticizing your partner a
little bit i'm talking about what's
happened
[Laughter]
oh now you got the 2d board exactly
exactly we were
this computer is not very easy huh no i
still prefer the three
at the board play all right let me see
let me see how team rex feels about
their oh what's going on here
transposing my foot here
how do you feel about the position
oh i think they should resign
because he said so yeah well you did put
the money so
yes we have a beautiful knight on d5
and uh
what else more do you want
i don't know far do you agree
the only thing which bothers me is that
we were winning
like mathematically winning like three
moves ago
[Laughter]
and now we're not mathematically winning
mathematically winning
this is deep calculation here for shock
considering it's a 10 minute game
[Laughter]
[Music]
i feel this is like cheating a little
bit team john is just discussing the
position you guys are just watching it's
gonna be like working maybe
yeah we should be we're more honest than
they
[Laughter]
are after shock it will be linear
and for team john it'll be wesley
deep shot
it's a new variant
talk to chuck before i enter the game
i'm too late for that
wesley
chuck you thought for two minutes on e5
do you think the person after you will
be able to find all the tactics okay i
mean
[Music]
still i don't know it's good or not it's
just interesting so more important than
good right yeah yeah it's just very
interesting
it was very good position but maybe it
was e5 i don't know it's good or not
just very interesting all right well if
the sacrifice doesn't work we can blame
it on linear right
john how do we feel about the position
i'm feeling pretty good we're up on time
is that because you're just looking at
the phone
no
that was my ending position no no yeah
there's anti-cheating you know here yeah
true don't worry no 15 minute delay in
this one though
we don't need to cheat we got this you
got this
well let's see let's see
we have
upon sacrifice on the board
very deep thought here by wesley so
i feel i feel these guys are having way
too much fun
but can you have too much fun really i
mean with this position i think black
can have too much fun at some point
very intense match at the moment
maxine
hello why aren't you playing
um i don't know
but
i wasn't selected i was not no i'm not
he didn't make a cut yeah i didn't make
it to the champions showdown i think
that's the main reason because all 10 of
the players today
are playing the championship that's way
too much logic
way too much
no
peter spiller who is playing the 960
asks
we're professionally asking if maximus
played the knight 60 which we just had a
drawing of lots for the fact that i'm
not playing a good point yes
a point that may have
occurred to me yeah but technically you
don't need to prepare for your
opponent's game for the 960.
[Music]
so we are now interested in the
interesting phase of the competition
where linear will think for 23 minutes
did have the longest thing of the sing
field cup he had the longest thing the
second longest the third longest and the
fourth longest think of the same
kilogram
he's trying to beat his own record right
now
yes
[Music]
some of your best impersonations of
maurice
who maurice
during commentary maui's story
yes
we'll get that later right now i think i
would scare the players
this is excellent because this is an
actual frenchman pronouncing maurice's
name as maurice
which is something i was criticized for
i'm pretty sure i'm not doing that but
this is an actual frenchman saying
maurice instead of maurice
morris from brooklyn yes i will make
impersonation impersonations on that
later
like a true frenchman but we are way off
topic guys let's get out of here
absolutely let's go back to team john
i mean the game is so slow i'm going to
talk to people
guys
yeah well
uh we thought bishop e4 was a great move
alireza recommended queen a5 we're
looking now at h3
bishop takes f3 bishop takes f3 knight
takes d4 bishop takes h5 maybe i have a
knight f6 check just the fun
why are you helping team john
i i just happened to be in the wrong
place at the wrong time
there was no bank transfers nothing
nothing nothing this is like a
free roll a gratis oh terrible alright
how do you feel about the help
yeah it's it's a great help but
it's now getting tricky i don't know
do you like your position
okay after hd
but maybe there are good moves that
could save but
it's getting tricky if it's a maybe
coming from you who's going to see it
i trust whistling
oh and the variation that they just
calculated on the board right now
was much better
a7
a7
no no no a7
good i just missed h3 but yeah but but
it was all forced because alyresa forced
me to
go for this huh i think i asked him what
to play huh i feel the ascension in the
ranks here guys come on
guys
but before before you comes rex where
you survive this yes
i don't know but it's
probably my best chance
let's see how the game is progressing
here
maestro
now he's going to do paquito
say what
i'm not sure what that is yes this is
coming the mate is coming this is
another predicted this ten months ago
yes
but he's gonna have to get up
and next
is rex singfield himself
rex
don't blow it
well that's
oh now that rex is playing i'm sure
we're doing amazing is rex going to
finish it off yeah i mean he cheated a
little bit before he told lenier
how to conduct the attack
that's true
they're on the retreat
are you surviving
me
i'm not playing this game yeah
the great concern of everybody on the
team john is
they don't want to tag him
[Laughter]
they don't want to be the guy
who has to
extend the hand and fellowship i have to
say it a lot of worried faces on this
side of the room
i mean joshua's not even in the game and
he's worried
[Applause]
any suggestions what i can can think
about i mean only it's a very very sharp
and very important moment yes rook f3
great move
shock what do you think about this move
[Laughter]
now rex gets to show his brilliancy
yes
that was quick
[Laughter]
gary how was your position after
i john you and i can match
i'm sorry we'll fight back
yes
there are always chances i mean it's so
little respect no i'm an amateur but not
but everything
i have to make sure
not so
we're going to fight
i was about to you know just prepared
myself psychologically to reside
[Laughter]
oh well rex you know was very generous
he spares his spare my my honor
he's always been a very generous donor
what happened to rocks
yeah it's the magic again
again
can i say it
i'd like
rex what's your inspiration for the
bishop uh sacrifice a mistake a mistake
anastasia didn't teach me that
being blamed over there
he's blaming you for the peace sacrifice
it was the wrong inspiration probably at
least particular moment
[Laughter]
i will do better next time i will do
better
[Laughter]
what is the hope here guys
we are going to survive for 15 moves
it is not necessary to define what it is
we just know it springs eternal spring
hope springs eternal
that gets out of here
all right
we're going to show resilience
resilience
yes in the moment of danger
is
nothing but resilience
nobody wants to resign these games but
is anybody mentally prepared
no
never
our only issue is that we have a queen
upon g3 and not a bishop on g1
then it would be
then it would be okay 960 starts
tomorrow
yeah we could have gone for a meeting
i mean sales stalemate traps if there
was a bishop on g1 and no pawn on g3
right with the king on h2 we will
no that's a strong check yasser it's a
strong check
but he missed e4 nice left leg
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
no suggestions
[Laughter]
[Music]
kg4 is missing
[Applause]
right
probably regret it now
oh
[Music]
so much gamesmanship right there well
disgusting
what a troll yeah yes why is everybody
analyzing this so seriously
it should be an important position in
the context of things i don't know what
first things are but it's an important
position this
well the problem is i only have five
moves to win this or else i think
all results are possible
wait wait you gotta trust them i'm john
[Music]
rex is going to check mate
and if i don't do that i'm probably
maybe not losing
yes i'm aware
good wait for me
you can do it
yes
nerves of steel no fare
no fare
i must protest this treatment
[Laughter]
[Music]
be careful
well i think uh team team john is
celebrating their victory a little
prematurely because
[Laughter]
because john is ready
we have to make the stalemate
thanks kind of hard with this time
peter thank you have you given your team
chances
i think i i've given them and then i
think them away
at the yeah time let's see how the game
progresses
maximum was important
white could be mating
absolute silence in the room
that's a good team member
[Applause]
the queen counts
between you guys
john has promoted
to a queen except he promoted to a white
queen
t-rex is saying that that should stand
and it's their queen now and that's five
moves
i think that should be our queen
[Applause]
and that is checkmate that is a lot of
queens on the board that's 1-0 for team
john to start the match
that's right
they changed the rules for rex
won two games and the third year were
winning and i think it was on c file and
and we are just to promote i l i let rex
want to promote and he just uh and you
learned your lesson
yeah but that we lost the game yeah and
now now it's not that it's not fair i
thought he had to to receive the
compensation we're going to do a little
trivia for younger viewers in which very
famous game
two of two soviet players
and one of them being here
one side promoted to a queen
by saying uh
the russia the english word queen
and his opponent demanded it to be a
knight because he said it's coin in
russian
no i didn't play that year but that's
the clue but it was a very famous moment
by the way did you guys see
yes did you guys see the deadly trap
rex had set on the final move
queen c6 c6h1 was checkmate but queen c6
to e4
was stalemate
devilish devilish
it was so close
we're moments away from starting game
number two same rules different colors
that's it
we got official explanation for what
happened
so there was two illegal moves
there was two illegal moves the first
illegal move was he pushed the bond with
for promotion without making it a queen
second illegal move was he replaced it
with the queen of the wrong caller
two illegal moves in a blitz game lose
but because they were made on the same
move it only counts once
chris bird arbiter do you agree with all
of this absolutely yeah that's exactly
the ruling that was on the game
ruling on the game is it continues and
team jon wins
rex you can overrule that
no i can't
uh just waiting for the screen to just
change real quick and then we're gonna
be ready i think we are a second away
from starting
[Music]
what strategy needs to change for you
guys to win
uh we need to make
no we need to make sure rex is relaxed i
think there was too much tension on him
too much pressure yes
because he had to find the mates
thank you
accelerated
how does
okay
so what is the order for this one um
um and then the regular team order uh
but fabio first and then ala razer and
then the regular team order
fabulous
so we see an opening battle between
alireza and fabi
[Music]
yes very classy we want everyone to have
the privilege of following rex
privilege we're calling it
let's get him
no but i mean it doesn't make any sense
are you sure
i know two things
hey if you're white you normally should
not accept campus
if you're black you should
but
i wasn't taking my life but my wedding
the audience i just saw on twitch on
youtube everywhere they're very unhappy
about you not taking that bishop
yeah i thought that i i need to take
some responsibility
[Laughter]
i mean the honor remember of chicken
[Laughter]
okay
definitely
it's improving
after the first five moves i'm very
surprised we were not doing well and now
we're i think much maybe not much better
but i like it now objectively where
rexas moves better than elereza's
no
d5 our position just became amazing
it's all fabiana's fault
ariana you take that
knight e4
followed by knight d6 and knight g5 yes
he said
the position speaks for itself
[Music]
everybody's nervous all they need is a
draw team john needs a draw
but everybody's nervous what do they
need to draw
to clinch the match it's four games oh
darn it
now we're even more nervous
[Music]
wow
wesley
is
[Laughter]
oh shoot
oh shoot
i got a life
each player is trying to sacrifice one
piece and if it doesn't get taken the
next player tries to sacrifice a piece
how is that going for them well i didn't
take the first piece but chakriar took
the second piece so we're doing well
live on
it was a strategic decision you knew
that the sacrifice is coming
she decided to wait for a better moment
to take
what do they do then
they try to get the stalemate
[Music]
where's the compensation
[Laughter]
the compensation was approved with jan
apparently
answered this one
oh no sir
no but definitely
[Music]
[Laughter]
peter is next
actually before immediately yeah
why is there so much analysis on
something that didn't happen because
it's interesting and we're test players
in the current position
i think this won't last too long we'll
win
we'll convert
linear with one more move and one more
night
gary how about the suggestion of
resigning a business
for the last time
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm sure gary is going to show us an
example
by resigning
everyone
yeah this is
we're going to get a nice square for a
night soon
and just relax
and not think
the amount of trust being shown with me
here is staggering
everyone is still trying to hint me much
absolutely not i was
trying to inspire anybody
ideal inspire uh yen and lavon
we've got a one point lead which is good
but yeah a little nervous
[Music]
what do you think of gary's attempt
he's intimidating them right now that's
what he's doing
yes
[Music]
a bit too daring
this is your hint that knight will go to
a good square and you really might be
too
solid square
squared
yes is it going to bring in the attack
is going to bring the compensation oh
maybe maybe we'll we'll see we just have
to survive a few more moves and then
then once john takes over he'll beat rex
so i feel good
oh
[Music]
almost
guys you see me you seem very excited
for a team that's down to peace
you go to b6 but then i go bishop d16g
you take the rook queen e2 and i mean
yeah
chances yeah yeah a chance i guess
there's bishop d4 but okay i mean it's
still yeah yeah yeah but
it wasn't it was crazy because a moment
ago
there was this
interesting possibility of queen d3
after king g8 we thought peter had blown
it our initial thought was it was bone
there was this crazy move bishop on g7
the d4 blocking the threat to the knight
on c4 and everybody went quiet
we were all excited
so one more move one more move
[Laughter]
remember this night being on that bike
it is a nightwell track
nice career for someone from from
been working with peter for the last
week or so and
helping him with his tactical skills
it's paying me off
oh yes ask questions
uh
come on some prophylaxis okay i'll
i manage the restful axis
but why
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is this demands can we do it
mechanically i don't wanna be cheating
here for three minutes
um
come on peter finish them off okay
that's it sorry
i'm ready to accept your resignation
this won't be easy
the knight ended up on a good square
class you said it would happen
okay
yeah
it happens to me like every next game
here
for most of the night did it improve or
i like yeah
in particular against gary landing in
light on d3 is a very very satisfying
feeling right yes
now that i would know
claiming to have no knowledge of knights
on d3 in kasparov's games
never heard of it yeah yeah not familiar
yeah not familiar
okay okay that's what you're going with
yes
all right it seems like we might be
winning more material is unnecessary
unnecessary i think there was a
technical issue with this actually yeah
of something of some description
i don't know let's take a look
i choose safety first
i have two more moves yes you have one
more one more
ok
well the rest is easy
one can you solve all your issues
i think so
and more or less uh with my last move
showed the plan and
the rest is
the rest is the matter of technique if
you could draw iris on the board you
would
huh you can draw arrows on the board you
think rooks are driven yes for sure
good start
very good
hey hey hey same hand yes sir
whose side are you on
hey i'm coaching the team john what are
you doing
let's keep them on the street narrow
yes
my team approves
very good
oh are you worried no
you don't look good at all
yes
[Music]
rex are you proud of that one yes sir
wow
it was such a silence right everybody
was kind of like
they're breathing everybody saw it but
we didn't know what rex would
check
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you just won with the black pieces
thanks to rex brilliant defense
i told you i wasn't worried i knew that
rex would find bishop b5 it was obvious
it was a hundred percent clear
rex were you a hundred percent of that
move
it's obvious the day is long
[Laughter]
it is a drawn match one to one guys so
competitive
i think being up a piece is the key in
this match i don't think the
compensation has worked a single time
i think people are going to have to
temper their sacrifices a little bit
here clearly
john and rex came to
play yesterday
[Music]
uh so it's uh
jack will follow rex in this one and
carol will follow john and then their
teams will follow the same order to have
been going that's good
that was good all right gentlemen just
give us a second here
so
[Laughter]
yeah
interesting
do you not like your position i'm
confused whether it's bad or it's
completely fine
the quarter's a little bit [ __ ]
absolutely
[Laughter]
but what to do but at ultimate moves
don't you play knight g5 every time
but d5 is amazing
amazing yeah it's really good yeah
yeah
sometimes
[Laughter]
i'm not kidding it's some strange animal
from black for sure
the car was considering considering c5
yeah
i think i'm like
[Laughter]
what to do
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
shaq said that you wanted to sack a
piece but they didn't want to play
without it
oh yeah the third i thought this team
event everyone has to take the burden
you know some
this was the time i was here
okay
someone no someone has to fear someone
who other people blame
i think they prepared this opening
before the game
it looks like some yes some preparation
oh you can play the hidden title tuesday
yeah
wesley was the sacrificial god
no i i know there are other members of
the team who can't carry me
start stressing on ian and stuff
but they didn't
exit
okay but 1-1
we're not
yes actually i've never seen this
position before
that's what
but it can't be so good you play queen
seven now yeah take six can get let's
see
[Music]
it sort of reminds me of okay all these
like 35 should be seven i think some
yeah
uh this you know weird lopez ranks yeah
okay like black is definitely not better
no i think we need favorites
like it's better i'm just starting to
win a piece with c5
i don't know
okay
i mean white house maybe bishop g5 man
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
yeah this was crazy moment so i went up
to gary and i asked him carry it
after this move c5 it's crazy what's the
best move say i don't see immediate wind
maybe c2 c3 is it c3 i never consider it
i asked ali ali what's the best movie it
was knight c6
go 96 i didn't see it
i'm surrounded by geniuses this is not
this is not very good of me to be here
it's feeling feeling a little bit you
know haris hey you know this is treated
this is why we do commentary that's
exactly right
oh
there's never even material in these
games yeah well you will be in a moment
right four maybe two or three moves
this can be crucial yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you think of the opening
i think it's going great
that's the question
but you know
the
the tricky part is rex is really strong
in accelerated dragon
so he gets also black on the next game
are you saying playing black is an
advantage for rex
it's very good for him yes
you're saying his white rapper is trash
no it's very good but in excellent
dragon like i saw him play the club he
won everything i mean that was just one
game but he won it and then he won it
again now winning everything you're
talking about alerts are not rocks no
rex he's playing people at the club he's
really good in accelerated dragon and
they allowed him to get it here in the
first round
or the second one right and now he can
get it again in the fourth round and
that i don't know how good the other
players know the opening but rex and
exodus the dragon that's
that's a great match it's all about the
weakest link anyway right
i
oh
oh really yeah
[Laughter]
sorry have you heard
[Laughter]
make anything
even remotely
mushrooms
one moment
how do you think you came out of the
opening i think we're doing fine you
actually can tell when everybody's like
really quiet they actually think it's
very interesting and something something
that could be uh could be analyzed but
when everyone's very loud you know it's
just like all fun but the quietness
shows that it's very serious game and
everyone's interested in this opening
we're still not to the point where it's
clear yet who's better
which side would your daughter take
uh
i would probably prefer white but not by
much not by much but it's getting into
an end game and so we'll see who who who
can play the end game better probably a
draw
probably a draw probably yeah we're
getting into some end game it's going to
be boring
i guarantee you guys this will not be a
draw
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you're currently
we're sorry about the audio delay i
think we are back in action
the 2d board has updated and
i believe
this is the last move for peter
jumping in is levon
what black's position
[Music]
yeah i think so
and the position
well we have a small edge a small
advantage which is good
who do i play against
is it ollie rosa
uh you'll play against wesley
is very solid
i was told
in an interview actually by hans
that we should all model wesley's
approach to chess
risk aversion
risk aversion that's what that's the
word he used so is that why they keep
sacrificing pieces
well last time he was the one who so
he's trying to break that stereotype big
mistake no
it ended up being a mistake that's true
how does this kid see so many tactics
alireza sees everything
nobody is jumping around on my watch
[Music]
[Music]
95 now and 96 should be yeah still king
is three maybe king this three maybe
gary you guys are calculating too many
moves you know that john and rex jump in
pretty soon right
we're we're we're anal we're animals
we're trying to understand so what's the
there's a position to be discovered
i've been analyzing it with anastasia as
well we think it's a good fight i think
all three results are possible
and your prediction
all three results impossible
that's my story i'm sticking with it
you're the one that got the prediction
right for the sinkhole cup
come on
look at the competition you know me come
[Laughter]
i did finish last in that competition in
the prediction competition
but your horse fell out of the race huh
who wins the showdown
the showdown yeah what's your prediction
that's my prediction
i mean
i know very well who is going to win
like
you cannot win two and not three yeah
it's always friendship french
ship
that as well
that as well yes very very nicely in the
past two years
uh there was only one event where a
frenchman was participating but we
didn't win is uh the showdown of last
year because i didn't have ah that's
missing from the trophy bookcase
i would correct that
you got two horses in the race this time
huh it's a lot of pressure fun i'm not
playing you're not playing
yes are you dude we've been here for
like an hour dude he hasn't made a move
not here
he's we're talking showdown yeah that's
the same yeah what's the difference this
is the most important one that's true
good point
at least we have a spectator here yes
interested spectator obviously oh i'm
not interested in the chess
i'm here for the company
the
ship all right let's go back to the game
my cheers
here
well they could
is
you don't think white is better here
[Music]
anything can happen that's right
it's any good of course
of course
i really thought you were meant before
yeah me too now before you just stay can
you completely
this looks like
and rex is the master of games
but wesley didn't give away a piece
yeah
this is very important
so we want
is
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i feel of this sound game is
the king went the wrong way
yeah i was definitely winning if not
king of four
[Music]
it's a club remodeling going on that's
why we moved from the club
to this space
they started a little early today
[Laughter]
what do you think of the end game
i think now black is is very good we
were worried about king e4 and king d5
and we thought that white was going to
win that you're not you're not playing
you're fully invested in team genre
totally totally i mean as a coach you
know my my team comes first i mean it's
my sole priority in life these days
against rex
well team john
[Laughter]
all right let's see the game all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that we have the start of a new game
here
yeah and the time
like this game won't be decided by chess
that that's what i i have a feeling
it's going to go
down to the last few seconds and
someone's going to blunder a piece
someone maybe someone we know
[Laughter]
somebody could be in the room
minute 30 against two minutes on the
clock
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah do you think we're losing 25 more
moves yeah huh yeah they all they need
to move the king back and forth and then
i think it's like john's playing better
than me so
looks like you're 50.
diameter
[Music]
gary
you think white says this
no i think i think we're going to win
this
and then all we need to do is draw with
white next game easy no
well not with john's opening i'm not
sure
we need to
we need to prepare a drawing line
against the accelerated dragon yes very
important
so much work into getting this knight
from c6 to e6 and then gary puts it back
[Laughter]
what did you
is
bishop g1 or something h4
bishop h2 i mean already at that point
i got knight c6
king c4
kings goes into seven and then with the
95 knight takes a free that's okay yeah
but wait
so after c5 which moved
okay let's see i keep the bishop on g3
so i play c6 no i play king e6 first
[Music]
confidently played
i'm not sure what's happening i'm not
super optimistic but
they have more pawns which is the issue
that is an issue
[Music]
all right tens ten seconds for level one
yeah but i had no move what could i do
peter's panic didn't pay off
no peter but king you too big hill
[Music]
thank you
lavon is unhappy
wow what a victory there everything
could have happened
absolute magic magic do you like that no
and that's 2-1 for team john team rex
needs to come back with a victory with
the black pieces
rex do you feel the pressure now
you feel pressure
much pressure
black black is one every time that is
true
yeah they're all unhappy with me
probably correctly but like
it was bound to happen at some point
right
what was supposed to happen tell the
audience well the fish you know the fish
at some point like
show starts showing its true colors
the star fish i mean no we are the kind
of fish
we're about a minute away from starting
here actually seconds away from starting
here in this position let's see if rex
uses his accelerator dragon to come back
in the match
why we pay you the big bucks chris
that's
fine
this looks familiar
it's a winning line for black right
there's one little change
i had this position
then you should be ready
will you still drink for five minutes
[Laughter]
okay
maybe you should place free that's right
he said
[Applause]
is
this is the previous end game yeah what
happened who lost it
they lost it
[Laughter]
98 actually was not the best move so
because they could have saved the game
is if the instead of c5 they could put
the bishop on c5 and then but instead of
knight d8 knight f4 check
because we had to stop c4 king before
and now h5 c4 exchange and then h4 you
cannot take because h3 so that's why and
that and since you know that unless you
don't play c4 then just easily win
four
yeah yes it seemed to me like the end
game turned around john playing racks
just simply outplayed racks no the move
d5 was incredible like that was really
high skill you know
i i think the indian was fine for black
so i think this is probably was equal
because but they're very sharp because
white white could have run to this pawn
but again king d5 and king the fight
c4 or b4 i don't know which order after
after work b it takes six takes and then
you go c4
ah sorry sorry the wrong position
really really competitive
all the males
disgusting position
and not giving it up
it's my carcass no it's mine you're
going to be talking about this for two
days
at least at least it was a good position
it was good with three results
correct good job predicting that thank
you very much what about the current
position
i actually really like black's position
team rex
rex keeps getting his his much wanted
accelerated dragon he knows it he feels
it
so right now i'm worried about 2-2 as a
coach as a coach as a coach a coach i'm
worried about tutu all right well let's
let's take a look okay let me think
i approve whatever enjoy
you have a great counter
you know
some things are just inevitable
the fact that he is thinking
about the point
at the board but okay
it's only
we invested
i like how my team is playing is that
good
yeah i think back on e6
this is your last chance
and you're on the cruise
we ending up
of course
do you need any coffee with your donuts
wow
[Laughter]
to try the donut
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
i don't even know what to play here
wow
[Music]
without preparation just to do some
scouting yeah okay i can like play
bishop c7 yes
mr c7 i approve
[Laughter]
anything
we're grabbing upon them
you know
security
you can even improve bishop d6 rook d8
bishop c7 now
yes you forked the pawn
yeah
you have to open it just watch out for
the small completely forced do you think
it's threatening
i think it is
yeah i guess he is
don't listen to that
is
[Music]
take your time wesley
[Laughter]
yeah
such a high quality
is there armageddon
no no no no
nothing's happening
champions nice
i'll try to
not be too humble
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah but stop hinting it's not like
you're playing with friends and you're
just being no no i was not playing no
but generally you hit them three times
okay very disrespectful
it's like anish four years ago huh
but
we're playing and uh
if you're better than all of us then you
should play alone i guess
no even even magnus
anyway you're underestimating my know
my skills no no it's probably that's
your best chance
just to remind you last time i approved
it so you know it ended up
that's it
can you control yourself
as it is i told you i was worried
and now everyone went real quiet on us
that's a telltale sign right yeah that's
a telltale sign
tempest
the what tempest fusions
there must be a way
no i only have one more hope there
oh yeah
sacrifices
rex would you like a draw
what in this game
no you're the captain
no you guys can resign if you want come
on
we're being kind
oh
[Applause]
what happened to our attack
yeah we had to you know kind of get
solid
but we are slightly better
i like uh our knight so
and uh
everything will be decided in
in the later stage
two out of two with the accelerated
dragon
hopefully
that's something shocking
i mean i'm telling you the the players
have much better snacks than the
commentators this is delicious this is
unbelievable right i mean for two weeks
i've been eating granola bars
and ding dongs too by the way you get
granola bars right these guys get like
strawberry you know chocolate stuffed
strawberries
hummus potato salad
delis when's our strike
oh immediately
immediately dude immediately what do you
think of the position
um i thought for sure
team rex was on the attack
but uh i think they slipped it up and
now i feel the game's more balanced than
anything
but still
three results
three results
nothing changed in this game uh but
again earlier i was worried
i think the worst has passed for white
yeah there was a storm it was a storm
but it has it's been weathered yes
all right back to snacks absolutely
all the players are playing so now's our
chance
okay
yeah really annoying
in any way
i'm
look at that focus
two more minutes
under two minutes
the game may have continued
come over here to the french corner
what's going on here
yeah i was saying we're getting out
slowly but
i mean nobody's getting outplayed from
my perspective
also no
like the question is do i want a
tiebreaker
there's no tiebreaker there's no
typewriter
oh then i'm trying neutral
what if there was one
then of course you want to take veika
you want more surprises every year we
have 2-2 yes and no no play-off and it's
disappointing for everyone what's what's
going on we're asking the commentator
there's tony rich
there's the organizing committee
but you know you guys usually overrule
the broadcast and you're just like let's
play a tiebreak anyway oh yeah let's do
that again
i mean there was an occurrence of the
players
i mean ruling off the wolves and
actually not having a tiebreaker
can you comment on that fabiana
i don't have any recollection of that
no
yeah you don't win the sinkhole cup
every year do you
just sometimes so i'm probably suffering
for from sudden memory loss because i
remember it was there agreeing about the
playoffs
what's your version of the story
i i did have to play another playoff
that day i thought maybe two playoffs
was a bit too much for one day
there were some weird words like it was
a three player's dice so one player to
be excluded
there were some strange rules there were
some strange rules that year so we just
decided to
not play
this is what we call a strike at the top
level of chess that was a strike yeah
a multinational strike incredible they
got away with it too
but
in the game
we got the most important part here
coming up
okay
one
more all right here's that for you you
have one more
drop
just in
case open for negotiations
rex that was great play thank you
i didn't lose anything
so far
i'm not giving up
is
rex how do you evaluate this end game
i think it's irish
i think it's ours it's yours oh yeah
what's the advantage here linear
that's pretty good
somehow it feels a bit unpleasant i was
more excited
a few minutes ago
and then what happened
it doesn't have sex life happens
a man with evil intentions
no hands
you could play king of high bishop h5
and then threaten the petrol like this
i think we can't escape it
it's not attacking
it's an occasional yeah
this is
[Applause]
one minute
[Laughter]
they
[Laughter]
got ahead of myself is that a pyramidal
ian you're approaching you are probia
okay
wait
yeah that's quite unexpected
i look for a repetition
careful because you know when you stare
into repetition tradition stays back
um
what
now
[Laughter]
celebration
41 seconds each 30 seconds
yes
possible live oh it's five more good job
yeah it wasn't you can't stay there to
chocolate
the captain
yes
[Music]
very good
big chief hits excitement
part of my ideas
we're going to have a revenge
honeymoon two times
embrace it but
oh
yes
okay
you're next in here
okay it's a draw right three-fold
[Music]
[Applause]
chris what's the
ruling think rex was happy to settle for
a draw in that position yeah well
there's no scoresheets
i think when red when rex says it's a
draw it's official that's a draw yeah
sorry guys
well a strange threefold repetition was
accepted there by rex singfield and that
finishes the match team jon takes it two
and a half one and a half in a very
strange last game
but that was it for ultimate moves
this was intense much more intense than
i remember it being peter
that was that was very good i thought
excellent excellent yeah
what happened at the end with c3 i think
everybody was thinking c3 is going to
finish the game the other way yeah it
was it was a bit mysterious that didn't
happen but
what to do i think it's been lighter on
the trash talk this year than i've seen
it in the previous years better on the
chest
i think so yeah
gary did you see c3 oh yeah when i
played i played cb4 yes i saw c3 yeah
but then i just grabbed one [ __ ] one
day five we have to discuss the winner
of the team i mean and he played their
whole team
where where's your team john
teams here and it came down to
intelligence and good looks
wesley came in and played very slow to
put him to sleep right and then hikaru
would come in really fast to wake him up
and then gary would finish him off it
was a flawless plan i thought you
finished it off in the very beginning i
was just there to get more time on the
clock
that was my whole strategy well
congratulations on your victor how do
you feel
this was fun this was good
yeah when when it all cost
next up disneyland yes
when at all cost and remember that we
have the champions showdown nine lx
starting tomorrow it's one hour later
start time 2 p.m central
see everybody there fisher random coming
up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you